for good evening everybody welcome to
the press conference after the
extraordinary FAC thank you for waiting
has warned us again he did in the past
consoles but insisted on the fact that
in Libya there are several risk these
risks are increasing first the
terrorists risk more more is being
detected the presence of fighters coming
from Syria and also from Sudan second
the migration risk there are almost
700,000 according with his figures 700
thousand people coming from sub-saharan
Africa from other countries all of them
are working in Libya not all of them
want to go to Europe but depending on
the situation in Libya dependence
additionally whether they will go to all
because they may lost they may lose
their jobs depending of the situation
almost four hours working third risk is
the risk of the destabilization the
whole region from Libya Libya
wide-spreading to Sahel on the fourth
and new geopolitical scheme new actors
are appearing in Libya and Russia and
Turkey and the whole central
Mediterranean geopolitical can be
changed so we have a strong set of
reasons to move from rhetoric to action
the region cannot afford another war and
we call for an urgent distillation and
maximum restraint to every part the
crisis risk jeopardizing years of effort
to stabilize Iraq
especially given its implication for the
decisis work of the global coalition
against dyes condemned every attack on
coalition forces and we clearly state
that continue fighting dyes remains our
priority we call Oregon to go back to
full compliance with the GCP way without
delay and we relay on the international
energy atomic agency to continue to
monitor and verify Iran's activities we
will continue helping Iraq from any
point of view from the military training
from economics for security reasons we
have to avoid
the spiral of violence can create the
situation in Iraq that can be very
dangerous for all of us and destroy
years of work and efforts on the
rebuilding of this country the
terrorists risk more more is being